this is from Business Insider
representative Alexandria kaiser-cortez
said Tick Tock should not be banned in
her first video on the app on Saturday
the New York Democrats started her video
by saying this is not uh not only my
first Tick Tock but it's a tick tock
about Tick Tock do I believe Tick Tock
should be banned no
so she started a tick tock in order to
go on Tick Tock and defend Tick Tock
from all the people who want to ban it
in both parties
by the way uh let's watch a little bit
of that video so why would we be
proposing a ban regarding such a
significant issue without being clued in
on this at all it just doesn't feel
right to me and additionally this case
needs to be made to the public we are a
government by the people and for the
people and if we want to make a decision
as significant as Banning Tick Tock and
we believe or someone believes that
there's really important information
that the public deserves to know about
why such a decision will be justified
that information should be shared with
the public as well
great argument there it doesn't it just
doesn't feel right that's right that
really is her hug you can watch the
whole video it's that's essentially her
whole argument doesn't feel right
doesn't feel right to me
um
you know that's that at least that's the
argument that you'll present to the
public
doesn't feel right
well she also says that it's significant
this is such a It'll be such a
significant move to ban Tick Tock and I
agree it would be significant in that it
would be
you know it would be uh it would be a
significantly could be significant in a
good way
but it's also not
it's not significant in the way that she
she frames it
like it'd be this huge deal this huge
power grab to ban Tick Tock
um
it's actually not
it's it's really a pretty simple
equation here
all you have to do is is balance so it's
a balancing act
you know on one hand you have
the harm
that Tick Tock does
to the American people especially to
kids
and then you also have so you have the
harm that it that it does to children
who are obsessed with this app and spend
like all day just scrolling you know
when you've got when you've got millions
of kids who are spending hours a day
staring at their phone and just
scrolling through like zombies okay not
even not not not to even mention the the
content that they themselves are putting
on this app that will live in cyberspace
and infamy forever
um
so you have that harm and then you also
have the National Security concerns and
uh and all the rest of it so that in one
hand
and then you have to balance that
against the harm done by Banning the app
and by saying okay there are a million
apps you can use but there's one that
you can't this one's banned
well what is the harm exactly so we know
what the harm is here and it's quite
significant what is the harm in this
hand that we're worried about
what's the uh like dystopian scenario
what's the worst case scenario from
Banning Tick Tock in what way does that
hurt us as a country
I know how it hurts us to have it how
does it hurt us to get rid of it
even she can't explain that
the people defending Tick Tock can't
explain it
none of them have laid out okay if we do
this here are the ways boom boom boom
I'll I'll lay it out for you bullet
point here are the ways that it harms uh
this country it harms the American
people to get rid of it
so does a lot of harm by having it
doesn't really no harm by getting rid of
it
it's owned by a Chinese company to begin
with so what's the problem here
there really isn't one that'll do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
members block hope to see you there you
can become a member and use coded Walsh
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans uh and if we don't see you
there talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]